even in other books you may have a
writer who is saying something from his
perspective he's sharing his thoughts on
a manner now those words are written by
inspiration meaning God inspired that
those words will be part of the
Revelation so God will inspire that
Revelation without those words
necessarily reflecting God's thoughts
pay attention to this point pay
attention to this point God may have
let's say David or Solomon write their
thoughts on a given Manner and so God
inspired them to include those thoughts
but those thoughts do not necessar
reflect God's thoughts so we must look
to Those portions of scripture where we
are clearly reading God's thoughts those
parts of scripture that are clearly
revealing God's thoughts because not
everything a prophet says or does is
necessarily a reflection of God's view
on that matter they're written because
God God wants those things written as
part of inspired scripture without God
necessarily endorsing those thoughts
those words those actions and I'm going
to give you an example of this from The
Book of Job if you don't understand how
the Bible's inspired you will confuse
yourself go to job 14: 11- 15 job 14:
11- 15
watch here as water disappears from the
sea and a river becomes parched and
dries up so man lies down and does not
rise see no Resurrection Ariel pay
attention no
Resurrection he lies down that's it till
the heavens are no more they will not
awake nor be aroused from their sleep oh
that you would hide me in the in the
grave that you would conceal me unto
your wrath his pass that you would
appoint me a set time and remember me if
a man dies shall he live again notice
shall he live again all the days of my
hard service I will wait till my change
comes you shall call and I will answer
you you shall desire the work of your
heart so notice when a man sleeps he
doesn't rise when you die will you live
again he's not certain is he Ariel right
but wait look what he says in job
1925-27 job
1925-27 so a man live again when he goes
to sleep he's not going to rise but wait
job job 1925-27 for I know that my
redeemer lives and he shall stand at
last on the earth and after my skin is
destroyed this I know that in my flesh I
shall see God whom I shall see for
myself and my ey Shall Behold and not
another how my heart yearns within me
okay now job you confus me you just said
when a man dies shall he Rise Again a
man sleeps and he will Rises no more but
now you're saying after you're dead and
and your skin has rotted you will see
God in your flesh again with your own
physical
eyes you got that
Ariel see so you have to also be careful
in other portions of the book because
you may have Solomon saying something
what he says is inspired and that God
inspired that statement to be part of
the Revelation but what he says doesn't
necessarily reflect God's attitude it
may be God allowing him to express his
thoughts his doubts and making it part
of the inspired
record right see Muhammad IB jarus who
just came to worship and love the trium
god may the Lord seal you in his love
and keep you in love with the Trinity
forever and I pray that for all of us
look what he said the Bible is so
detailed it is amazing the Bible is so
detailed it is amazing
May our hearts
always be set a flame by the spirit with
passionate love for the Bible and the
god of the
Bible now did that answer the question
Ariel because I can give you more
examples of that right I can give you
further examples of that exactly Ariel
that's another one but do you want me to
give you some examples from Jeremiah
Ariel where what he says doesn't reflect
God's attitude although it's part part
of the inspired record Jeremiah says
something so stupid stupid that God even
tells him look man stop speaking
stupidly repent I'll make you a prophet
here notice the stupid things that
Jeremiah said that's part of the
inspired record Jeremiah
4:10 Jeremiah
4:10 see when we know how to handle the
Bible correctly it becomes amazing and
wondrous here look look Ariel everyone
God inspired Jeremiah to write these
words down God had Jeremiah write these
words Jeremiah as part of this inspired
scroll but notice what Jeremiah writes
down Jeremiah 4:10 then I said ah Lord
God surely you have greatly deceived
this people in Jerusalem what blasphemy
saying you shall have peace whereas the
sword reaches to the heart whoa Jeremiah
you wrote down God has deceived
Israel you deceived Israel by lying to
them and saying there'll be peace
something God never said God never said
and yet Jeremiah wrote those words so
those words were in by inspiration
meaning God had him write them down as
part of the inspired record but
obviously what Jeremiah said cannot be
God's reflection these are stupid
foolish words from a prophet of God who
should know better than to accuse God of
deceiving
people but now let give you another
example Jeremiah 15: 15- 21 Jeremiah 15:
15-
21 well I can't pronounce your name
dude Wy whatever I'm doing it right now
now read with me Jeremiah 15 verses 15
to 21 guys read this this gets even
worse Jeremiah 15:15 to 21 oh Lord you
know remember me and visit me and take
Vengeance for me on my persecutors in
your enduring patience do not take me
away know that for your sake I have
suffered rebuke your words were found
and I ate them and your word was to me
the joy and rejoicing in my heart I
rejoiced over your word I loved your
word I was elated over your word but
watch what
happened for I'm called by your name oh
Jehovah God of
hosts I did not sit in the Assembly of
the mockers see when people mocked I
didn't associate with them see this is a
lesson for us Christians we do not have
fellowship with blasphemers and mockers
we rebuke them and chasen them and have
nothing to do with them I did not sit in
assembly of those who mocked you nor did
I rejoice and and I sat alone because of
you because of you I sat alone I
wouldn't dare fellowship with
heathens for you had filled me with
indignation hatred towards what these
people are doing but watch this guys
watch how bad it
gets watch how bad it gets
gets verse 18 why is my pain perpet ual
and my wound incurable God because of
you I'm in pain day and night because of
you I'm in misery because people hate me
people mock me I have no friends because
all of them are evil I'm all alone
depressed and
sad for your
sake my wound is incurable which refuses
to be healed now notice the blasphemy
here will you surely be to me like an
unreliable stream as Waters that
wow the audacity of Jeremiah God you
said you Living Waters that would quench
me but the more I come to you the more
miserable I am the more sad and lonely
did you lie to me that you said you were
Living Waters that would thirst quench
my thirst because you're doing anything
but quenching my
thirst
wow now notice what God has to say post
Jeremiah 15:20 to2
Jeremiah 1520 to 21 cuz you got reversed
the way you posted it it came in reverse
order Jeremiah 1520 to
21 watch here what did God say in
response oh okay I'm sorry it's Jeremiah
1519 to 21 I skipped 18 He said in 18
sorry about that folks Jeremiah 151 19-2
my apologies because I was reading 18
but I skipped it for 19 I apologize now
notice God's response notice God's
response in Jeremiah 151 19-21 sorry
brother read Jeremiah 151 19-21
therefore thus says the Lord notice what
he says to what Jeremiah said therefore
thus says the Lord if you return then
I'll bring you back man Jeremiah had so
backslidden he had to repent for God to
turn him back and use him again if you
return repent then I will bring you back
you will ST stand before me if you take
out the precious from the vial you shall
be as my mouth let them return to you
but you must not return to them and I'll
make you to the people a fortified
bronze wall and they will fight against
you but they shall not prea Prevail
against you for I am with
you with you and deliver you says the
Lord did you catch what he said in verse
19 if you
repent and turn back I'll use you again
Jemiah had so backslidden that God had
to tell Jeremiah Jeremiah time for you
to repent
CU I can't use you like this and if you
stop speaking stupid things and only
choose the precious things and not the
vile things that you say then I'll make
you my prophet and spokesperson again
wow now can you put Jeremiah 15: 19 in
the King James
version Jeremiah 15: 19 in the King
James version
watch
here therefore thus sayith the Lord if
thou return then will I bring thee again
and thou shal stand before me and if
thou take forth the precious from the
vile Thou shalt be as my f my mouth let
them return unto thee but return not
thou unto them did you catch it Jeremiah
got to the point because of the
persecution folks you're in good company
how does this encourage you if a prophet
of God filled with the spirit whom God
spoke to dreams and Visions who saw
Jesus the word come to him and speak to
him invisible human form that's in
Jeremiah 1 could get to the point of
misery where he starts insulting God
accusing God of being a deceiver and a
liar who failed to keep his promise and
God not condemn him and destroy him in
his wrath but still be patient with him
and forgive him and restore him and then
still use him there's hope for all of us
There's Hope for all of
us notice how the NIV translates it post
the NIV one more time Jeremiah 15:
19 Jeremiah 15: 19 yep that was Jeremiah
we just read it Pedro didn't you just
read it Jeremiah 15: 15- 21 notice
Jeremiah 15:19 one more time notice this
therefore this is what the Lord says
if you repent and IV captures it
perfectly here it does a great job I
will restore you that you may serve me
if you UT worthy not worthless words
you'll be my spokesman the NIV captures
the Hebrew perfectly you see what it
says if you
repent then I'll restore you and you'll
serve me and if you stop saying stupid
worthless things you'll be my
spokesperson folks Jeremiah got to the
point because of the attacks and
persecution he was experiencing for
being a servant of God he got so tired
and miserable he started attacking God
God you deceived me you lied to me you
said you're Living Waters well Waters
quench I'm anything but quenched I'm
more miserable than ever before did you
deceive
me and God says Jeremiah you need to
repent you need to stop speaking stupid
foolish things and if you do I'll use
again as my Prophet but if not you won't
be used wow a prophet filled with the
spirit inspired by the
spirit Sees God in dreams and Visions
sees Jesus appeared to him as the word
of God in Jeremiah 1 in human form could
get to the
point of depression and sadness where he
now accuses God and attacks God and God
in his Mercy doesn't destroy him doesn't
consume doesn't say damn you to hell
but patiently says Jeremiah it's time
for you to repent son stop saying what
is stupid and foolish and I will use you
again and I'll work through you once
more if that can happen to them don't be
shocked it'll happen to us but what you
take away from this what you take away
from this is that even if you get to the
point that doesn't mean you're at a
point where there's no return and God
won't look upon you but God will damn
you and destroy you no even that point
God still loves you so much he's willing
to forgive you if you repent of your
nonsense now going back to Ariel and
everyone else do you think what Jeremiah
said in Jeremiah 15: 1518 is God's
thoughts do you think what Jeremiah said
in Jeremiah 4:10 that Jehovah deceived
Israel those are God's thoughts
he was telling us what God thought what
God was like and how God felt no so why
are they there because God inspired
Jeremiah to write down even these stupid
foolish insulting words that barded on
blasphemy as part of his inspired
Revelation what's the point take into
consideration not every statement you
read in the Bible is God's thoughts it
may be the thought of the writer who
doesn't
understand is having a
difficulty doesn't have all the
Revelation and the full understanding on
a given topic so he writes down what he
thinks and God inspires him to write it
down as part of that inspired record but
that doesn't mean these statements
reflect God's thoughts so a careful
reader of the
Bible a careful student of the Bible
will know how to interpret the Bible by
the grace of God's spirit in such a way
to know this is God's thoughts that's
the writer's thought that thought
doesn't necessarily reflect God's
thought but it's there because God
wanted that thought that statement to be
part of the inspired
record
right hope that answered the question